hi there today I want to talk about a
concept called inter leaving or
interleaving interleaved practice a
secret' enhanced learning technique to
learn more about it all you have to do
is google interleaving what it means is
and what the this interleaving research
shows is that if we compare two forms of
learning one where you what they call
massively or as a block deliberately try
to learn certain information or a
particular skill sort of massively
deliberately in a focused way and if on
the other hand you have another group of
people who learn one skill or one bit of
information then move on to another bit
of information and so they're sort of
inter layering or eating interleaving
they're learning what happens is
according to the results of a number of
tests that those who study in block
massively will learn that particular bit
of knowledge or skill better in the
short term while they are doing it
they'll learn better than the other
group that are learning in a staggered
or interspersed way but in the long run
the interleaved or staggered learners
will do better and this has and this is
apparently new and they're looking at
the reasons why this tends to open up
connections between neurons in the brain
or whatever but the results without
getting into the neuroscience the
results seem to be quite clear and I you
know googled interleaving and there's a
lot of sites and I read a few of them
and I invite you to go and read it and
to me this justifies and confirms to me
the the validity of what we do at link
because if I look at my own sort of
learning strategies first of all even
before we had link I would typically
by two or three starter books whether it
be SML teach yourself colloquial
not just one but a variety so that I'm
not trying to ace teach yourself and
learn everything and teach yourself all
I'm trying to do is expose myself to
some of the same material in different
sources the second thing is when I study
at link as I've said many times my
initial strategy and my initial goal is
to increase my familiarity with the new
language to acquire a lot of vocabulary
to be able to understand what I read and
listen it's not immediately to be able
to speak again because my experience has
shown that if I understand what I hear
if I have vocabulary if I have developed
familiarity with the language I will be
able to speak and so I can actually
delay starting to speak until later I do
look at grammar rules but again not
massively not with the intent of trying
to learn it and I have tried that I have
tried looking at German declension
tables or Russian declension tables or
French conjugation tables and sit there
and try to get it in my head but it
doesn't work whereas if I casually look
at it as a kind of refresher and then I
go back to reading and listening and I
start to notice some of those situations
over time when I go back for the third
and fourth and fifth time to look at
those rules eventually they start to
relate to something that I actually
experienced while listening and reading
so I am interleaving in that way another
way in which I interleave is that when
I'm reading a text you know first of all
a very easy material and difficult
material when I'm reading difficult
material there are a lot of unknown
words blue words at link so I then have
to deliberately go through and look
those up on the dictionary in the
dictionary which is connected to to link
of course and as we know most things you
look up in the dictionary you will
immediately forget however I've looked
it up in the context of this article
that I'm reading when I look it up the
blue word is converted to yellow when I
next encounter that word in another text
or when I read the same text over again
with all the blue words converted to
yellow I am forced to try to remember
that word which mostly I don't remember
so I click on it and I see it every time
I'm clicking on these words I'm actually
testing myself and one of the things
with this interleaved learning is that
you should regularly test yourself but
if you're learning a language every time
you are trying to make sense out of a
text every time you're looking words up
in the dictionary every time you're
listening and trying to understand in
fact you are testing yourself so with
this approach you are constantly testing
what you have been exposed to what you
have learned but you are trying to get
the brain to absorb so there is this
constant testing that's going on another
way things are interleaved is if I move
from different subject matter always
subject matter of interest to me because
I think that's a major major motivator
one of the problems with sort of block
studying tables of the declension tables
is that it's it's not a lot of fun so
people very quickly lose interest but
say in the case of with my Korean
learning listening to Kim Jung Hwa's
podcasts on literature even though I
didn't really understand it that well I
was strongly motivated to understand it
and that kept me going and gradually I
understood more and more and now as I'm
learning Ukrainian I'm quite motivated
to understand what people are saying so
I will read these Ukrainian texts
save words and phrases converting blue
words to yellow
read it again on my iPad where all the
words are now converted in yellow and I
can touch on them and and see what they
mean it and slowly but without ever
expecting to master anything I'm not
blocked trying to learn anything
I'm just exposing myself laying laying
these layers down and but motivated very
much by my interest in the subject
matter and so this is also I think a
form of interleague learning I do a
Cajun II go through my flashcards as I
said before in my own case I put the the
new word and the translation and the
captured face all in the front so again
I'm not trying to learn these words I'm
just going through them as exposure as
part of another layer of learning that's
kind of going on in the case of
Ukrainian I haven't yet looked at any
grammar resources because I'm sure that
it differs some from Russian but you
know let me first wait until I have
enough experience with the language then
I'll go and look at how you know
different cases or whatever differences
there are Ukraine now I'll deal with
that later so again it gets back to this
idea of not massively deliberately in a
focused rate trying to learn and master
one thing but rather exposing yourself
to a variety of different things I may
talk to people again I haven't yet
spoken to anyone in Ukraine and I don't
think I will for quite a while but in
the case of Korean in my 90 day
challenge in 90 days I think I had a
total of 13 hours of conversation not an
awful lot but I improved so that was
kind of layered in there as well never
for example with my conversations I
wasn't expecting to do particularly well
or expecting to achieve anything of
course we like to improve but it was
just another form of exposure another
activity I wrote because that was one of
the goals in the 90 day challenge and I
did a bit of that not necessarily
expecting to get it right or anything
but it was all part of this gradual
entered layering inter leaving of
different exposures to the language
always challenging myself because I have
to try to write I have to try to
understand and so forth so I think that
a lot of what we do at Lincoln why it is
so effective I think can be
explaining by these articles on
interleaving now I might be quite
selective in this trying to you know
find a justification for link II where
perhaps there isn't any so I look
forward to counter arguments from people
out there but in any case go have a look
at this whole issue of interleaving I
think it's very interesting interleave
as leaves and leaves on the tree
interleaving so go and have a look and I
look forward to your comments bye for
now